[Music]
nvidia's $300 RTX 460 releases tomorrow
with reviews going up today but also
kind of on Monday with some asterisk
restrictions and its most direct
competitor at least recent one is the
AMD RX 7600 which itself is
$300 actually it's 270 they changed it
before launch actually it's $250 now
because in the week since launch it has
dropped precipitously so uh $250 7600 is
the closest competition and uh AMD of
course making it as hard as possible for
us to retain any sort of accuracy while
discussing GPU price in a review now
this card is following up the 4060 TI
which was a massive waste of Hardware
given its positioning the problems with
that one primarily stemm from the narrow
bus width and frame buffer related
issues and we talked about all those in
our review it was one of our most
negative reviews and
years that I can remember so uh the bar
is low the 4060 TI itself was a $400
card that has now been as low as like
380 with sales recently so basically
what we're being told by the GPU
manufacturers is people not buying stuff
makes price go
down learn more in my economics 101
class the 4060 is the cheapest Nvidia
card introduced in some years so today
we're reviewing it and benchmarking it
against the 4060 TI the 7 600 the a750
and will also have several older gpus
those include the RTX 360 the 2060 and
the 1060 in our charts let's get started
with this one before that this video is
brought to you by Squarespace we use
Squarespace for our own GN store and
juggle complex multi-piece orders all
the time with it Squarespace makes it
fast for us to roll out new products
with detailed Pages full of galleries
videos and descriptors it's also useful
for your own resume sites for
photographer or project portfolios or
for starting your new small business
idea there's never been a better time to
try and start your new business than
right now and we can vouch that
Squarespace makes it easy visit
squarespace.com Gamers Nexus to get 10%
off your first purchase with Squarespace
so the very Basics the RTX 460 it's a
partner only launch there are no
Founders edition cards that means we're
working with a partner model and the one
that Nvidia chose to send out to
reviewers was the Asus dual model it has
an overclocking uh percent increase
option of up to 20% we tested at stock
is always but we have power numbers for
it with the OC applied now the biggest
limitation here is that memory bus which
is the same for all cars doesn't matter
which partner it is it's a GPU thing so
the memory boss is 128 bits wide it's
the same as the 4060 TI's memory bus
that is down from a 192-bit bus on the
3060 series cards however the uh cash
has increased significantly with the 40
series and that's been nvidia's number
one defense since they announced these
things like a couple months ago and
we've talked about that and then we
proved in the 4060 TI review that it
simply is not as beneficial as Nvidia
wishes it could be because increasing
the cash would be far cheaper than
doubling or even just increasing by 33%
the vram on the cards that they're
shipping uh so that limitation well and
also the bus width challenge so uh it's
the limitations here where nvidia's
trying to shrink the die size which
means axing the bus width and either
reallocating that die area to something
else or just cutting it entirely to
drive cost down uh while also reducing
the physical memory modules and the cost
of memory on the GPU that's what's
putting Nvidia in this position where
they're trying to drive up margins
they're trying to drive down cost to do
that and you end up with cards that are
just not scaling that well as you get
past 1080p so we're stuck in this weird
time Vortex of 2016 looking at 1080p for
a best case scenario for modern sort of
quote unquote lowend
gpus that was like not serious by the
way before someone's like lowend
reviewers $400 not low end now the best
thing that the 4060 has going for in
terms of that memory spec is the
reduction of its power overall not like
consumed power but performance and
that's because the limitations of the
memory may become less binding If
instead we are hitting limitations of
say fp32 units instead uh rather than
with a 4060 TI where you're definitely
becoming bandwidth bound the RTX 360
confusingly was a 12 GB card back when
it launched so the 8 GB here on the 460
is a reduction in frame buffer size the
3060 also had the 192bit bus width but a
smaller cache pcie further is limited so
it's actually on a by8 interface the
most positive thing is the MSRP the 3060
launched for $330 with the 4060 launch
it at 300 that's at least down and that
would be great the performance will also
be high so that's a move in the right
direction unfortunately though the scale
has moved so far for the GPU stack to
where the 4060 is comparative
performance meaning it's relative
scaling against its neighbors and
predecessors as compared to Prior years
60 series cards is perhaps more similar
to what we would expect of a 4050 if
using prior GP performance scaling and
naming schemes as long as the value is
there whatever at some point it is in
fact just a name but as we've discussed
before the real problem is what does the
name convey and in a scenario where the
community has a set expectation for what
a 60 series class card is and what it
does and what it's worth it's not really
reasonable to expect you can just oops
move all the names to the right a little
bit increase the price and not have
people minimally confused and maximally
feel ripped off which they do at least
for the last several launches now now
before we really get into it we also
have to be wary of nvidia's approach to
marketing this product so uh Nvidia
allowed for reviewers to post early
pre-embargo basically Impressions so one
Benchmark of the 4060 that's abnormal
this is typically everything has to be
held until the Embargo lifts so everyone
publishes the review at the same time uh
there have been a few exceptions to this
over the years but this particular one
is very restrictive and the past
exceptions that top of my head I can
remember weren't quite as constrained as
this one so here's how it worked uh
Nvidia basically reached out to a
handful of media Outlets we were
included in that and they asked do you
want to run early tests here are the
parameters we obviously declined or you
would have seen a video from us uh and
my understanding is that Steve from
Hardware unboxed also declined for
similar reasons um so the reasons we had
at least at GN were that it's only
cyberpunk it's only with this particular
uh game settings and we didn't get any
further into details than that because I
instantly was like No And to be fair our
rep expected that answer and there's not
even sort of the cover fire of this
isn't a new game it's not a new feature
it's just very explicitly chosen kind of
loses the guise of being for any reason
other than obviously marketing you know
I don't have the biggest problem with
other creators taking that it all comes
into the approach so if if it's
disclosed if they explained how it
worked uh and it's very clear then
whatever fine the more concerning part
is just the it's what is this Telegraph
from Nvidia which is we are concerned
about the reception of this product
that's what it telegraphs anyway we said
no and uh this is our full review so
let's just we're going to keep the
charts really objective run through them
and we'll talk about it at the end we'll
start with The Thermals and the fan
curve because it's actually really
interesting for this cart these are
specific more to the video card from
Asus than from the GPU on nvidia's side
for this test we ran a ray Trac workload
until a steady state and allowed it to
hold for 30 minutes this was in a fixed
ambient temperature of 21° C the GP
temperature spiked hard and then fell
down to about 58° C over time the
hotspot temperature ramped immediately
to 80° fell to 60 and then ramped back
to 70 this is extremely abnormal
behavior and it's indicative of a
terrible fan curve design line or very
bad contact with an overcompensating fan
we can determine which of those two It
Is by plotting the fan curve against the
right Axis we can see that it was too
late to start it kicked in just after
the load got bad and then it
overcompensated immediately as a result
and then it gradually backed off so the
contact is fine it was just a late start
bad hysteresis because the workload
remained constant during this time the
fan then started ramping again in the
middle before falling off and that's not
ambient fluctuation asus's hisis here is
improperly timed and is designed in such
a way that the user will be made hyper
aware of any ramps and damps because it
responds that much Asus has done poorly
in building its V bios and this is
something that can be corrected with uh
basically a bios update for your video
card whether or not they shipped the
retail ones like this we don't know but
at least the review sample came this way
now on to the games cyberpunk 2077 is
one of the more intensive games in our
test Suite so at 1080p the RTX 460 ran
at 86 FPS average which allows the RX
7600 lead of about 4% that's not a great
start for the 4060 the 4060 TI is 23% of
the 4060 here demonstrating why Nvidia
positioned this card the way they did
there had to be a reason to spend $100
more any less than
20% H it's even worse than it already is
for the 4060 TI in the previous
generation the 3060 TI was about 26%
ahead of the 3060 so at least this much
tracks the a770 and a750 are both
dangerously close to the RTX 4060 with
the a750 having been as low as $200
recently it still has hit and miss
drivers but it's improved so drastically
that it's become a relevant competitor
1440p is somewhat playable on this class
of card especially if you drop the
settings a bit the RTX 460 held 1440p at
52 FPS average with 1% and. 1% lows
times per proportionally to the cards
flanking it the 7600 56 FPS average
isn't a noticeable Improvement but it's
still better the a750 also outperformed
the RTX 4060 with the 6600 XT getting
dangerously close the 3060 TI leaps way
ahead at 62 FPS average and it's just
behind the 4060 TI as we talked about in
the 4060 TI review these lower end 40
series cards sometimes struggle as
resolution increases but we've noticed
and you'll see L throughout the review
that the 4060 at least seems to be in a
better position relatively than the 4060
TI was Let's test the continuance of
that scaling behavior in the same game
at 4K even though you wouldn't
necessarily expect playability here we
can study the performance to understand
the cards ranking the 4060 Falls
significantly behind regressing as
compared to the RTX 3060 Nvidia is
struggling to compete with itself here
as resolution boosts in this game with
even the RTX 20 60 getting
embarrassingly close to the 4060 this is
disappointing to see even if the card is
more likely used for 1080 or 1440p it's
just not what you want from something
that's many years newer than a 2060 once
again though it's clear why Nvidia wants
everyone using dlss it makes the new
stuff look a lot better than it actually
is and Final Fantasy 14 at 1080p the RTX
460 at 189 FPS average leads the RX 76
600 by 25% it's not a lot but for
nvidia's sake it's at least swung back
in the direction that benefits it the
0.1% lows are also significantly
bolstered on the 4060 as compared to the
RX 7600 and the RX 6600 XT and we'll
look at frame time charts individually
at the end of this review the 4060 TI
leads the 4060 by 133% compared to
previous generations though the 4060 is
ahead of the 3060 by 19% the RTX 206 by
30% and the GTX 1066 GB by 97% Intel's
Arc cards aren't as competitive here as
they were previously but they're still
hanging in there the a750 is 170 FPS
average achieves 89% of the performance
for 83% of the price when at $250 or for
73% of the price if it's on sale for
$230 which just was recently a 1440p
allows us to add some other cards back
to the Chart as load ramps enough to
decrease the CPU B the 4060 Falls just
behind the a770 here and its 119 FPS
average has it between that and the a750
lows are similar between these three
cards and the RX 7600 is beaten by 8% so
Nvidia has climbed here relative to our
first game we were testing
generationally the 4060 still holds 22%
lead over the 360 similar to the 1080p
spacing although the 3060 TI outmatches
the 4060 at 4K the RTX 460 held 53 FPS
average and sat again between the Intel
Arc carts its lead over the competing RX
7600 has expanded to 15% finally
establishing a meaningful gap between
the two of them generationally the 460
holds a 19% lead against the 3060 so
it's at least not struggling as much as
the 4060 TI was against the 3060 TI
where we often saw equivalent or in the
worst cases the 3060 outperforming the
4060 TI as for the ti its lead is about
20% % over the 4060 with the 3060 TI in
the position we showed in our 4060 TI
review an embarrassing lead now for F1
at 1080p the RTX 460s 145 FPS average
has it functionally tied with the RX
7600 in averages however the 4060
maintains far better 1% and. 1% lows in
this particular game it'd be the actual
Victor here given just those 2 the RX
6700 XT is actually a compelling
alternative as long as those 310 to $330
options last it holds a 33% lead over
the 4060 for likely the same price as
most other partner models that one would
make the most sense at the price in the
scenario the Intel Arc cards struggle
with this particular game and they have
since launch they're both towards the
bottom of the chart at 1080p
illustrating why we still can't give the
a750 a sweeping recommendation it's
still more of an enthusiasts card at
1440p the RTX 460 held 106 FPS average
reducing its lead over the 360 to 16%
the TI's 26% lead pushes it to 133 FPS
average but the 6700 XT maintains a lead
even ahead of that and it's still
available in this price class as for
amd's RX 7600 it's again technically
tied to the 4060 but it's behind in lows
and Arc remains behind as well finally
at 4K the 460s lead over the 3060
shrinks to 12% it's still ahead at least
but the Behavior between the 360 TI and
4060 TI has carried down the stack
they're just far enough apart this time
where it's not as bad the a770
technically pulls ahead but given its
struggles comparatively in this title we
wouldn't recommend it over the 4060
total Warhammer is another highly
intensive game in our suite at 1080p the
RTX 460 landed at 105 FPS average ahead
of the a770 in average FPS but also more
significantly ahead in lows the 3060 TI
outd does the 4060 here as does the 6700
XT although neither by as impressive a
margin as we've seen previously
critically the 7600 is within range of
the average FPS of the 4060 again but
remains behind in lows and we'll look at
frame time charts at the end cuz they're
kind of interesting at 1440p the 460
remains sandwiched between the arc cards
still with advantaged lows though while
the 7600 trails in all metrics here the
uplift over the 36d is 16% so still a
better generational gain than basically
0% that we saw in the 4 360 TI and 360
TI but this game is challenging to run
at 4K so let's move on to the next game
shadow of the Tomb Raider is next in
this one the RTX 460 ran at 158 FPS
average separated from the 4060 TI by a
30 FPS Gap or 18% the 60700 XT is ahead
of the 4060 by 14% keeping it on the
short list of desirable cards for Value
right now against the new 7600 the 460
holds a 5% lead which isn't a big enough
Gap to really care about especially if
there's a price difference and the lads
are close enough to be basically noise
between the results Intel's Arc a750 is
unfortunately challenged in this one
it's facing the same immature driver
issue that Intel has had in some of the
other games the a750 is9 FPS average
allows a massive 50 FPS Gap or about 45%
between it and the 4060 although Intel
has clearly become fiercely competitive
in some titles it still has less
predictable Behavior overall in Tomb
Raider at 1440p the 460 ran at 103 FPS
average and was about tied with the 7600
given the new $250 pricing of the 7600
sometimes anyway it depends on which one
you look at that's really just not good
positioning overall for the 4060 Nvidia
doesn't even have a Low's advantage in
this particular title for the ti cards
the 4060 TI has 22% lead so that appears
to be about the average between these
games the 3060 TI is dangerously close
to the 4060 here and encroaching on the
4060 TI but we already know that story
The 6700 XT deserves yet another mention
although certainly not lawn for this
world it's carrying a 22% lead over the
4060 at about the same price at the time
of writing we don't know how long that
stock will last but they must have
enough for now out of curiosity we'll
quickly look at 4K as well this is
mostly important to understand if the
4060 and 3060 behave as the 360 TI and
460 TI that answer is no but the
behavior still matches the 4 60 was 21%
of the 3060 in the 1440p test it was at
28% ahead in the 1080p test but it's
only 133% ahead in the 4K test so that
is diminishing significantly with each
resolution increase fortunately it's not
diminishing at a pace where it becomes
realistically relevant or limiting which
is contrary to what we saw in the 4060
TI versus 3060 TI comparison and that's
on display right here once again but it
still shows the architectural shift
favoring 1080 p as someone who's been
reviewing cards long enough now to
remember 1080p with high settings being
a big deal on $200 cards it hasn't
gotten any less weird that we're still
there today the software landscape has
changed games have changed but it seems
like we're still targeting 1080p Horizon
zero Dawn was one of the worst case
scenarios for the 4060 TI versus 3060 TI
comparison so it's back this game was
particularly challenging for the 4060 TI
because of the boss width and frame
buffer limitations the 4060 ran at 143
FPS average at 1080p which has it about
tied with the RX 7600 AMD also benefits
here because its lows are technically
higher the int cards remain toward the
bottom of this chart so they're out of
the consideration for this one and
generationally Nvidia posts about a 15%
gain over the 3060 here 41% over the
2060 and about 133% over the 1060 at
1440p the 4060 TI led the 4060 by 16%
with 3060 TI about the same in rank the
7600 is functionally tied with the 4060
again in all metrics and the 6700 XT
retains an 18% lead over the 4060
compared to the 3060 the 460s lead is
only 12% this time that's slimmed down
from some of the other tests just to
study architecture again at 4K the 4060
leads the 3060 by only 11% here so the
Gap is dropping the 4060 also is at risk
of struggling with textures as playtime
extends in some of these titles that are
vram heavy even the K750 is about caught
up with the 4060 Now power consumption
is up now Nvidia originally leaned on
power consumption as its main marketing
point for the RTX 4060 specifically
mentioning how much money can be saved
over a 4-year period which is a long
enough time scale that we know Nvidia
definitely doesn't want you to own that
card that long anyway but it's a reach
for something positive is the point we
always test power anyways we're going to
look at that uh and the RTX 460 pulls
about 120 watts under a full load so in
the sense of power consumption they're
right it is generally efficient
particularly against the previous
generation the Asus dual card offers an
additional 20% power offset and that
should increase it to about 144 Watts by
math but given the firar power virus
Behavior Uh it ends up at 164 Watts with
an OC the 120 watt number is the most
relevant though that's stock that's less
than the RTX 3050 previously and it's
about 40 Watts under the RX 7600 so
again it's true that Nvidia is more
efficient but the multi-year savings
argument is just really weak first of
all you of course have to look at the
Delta between the power consumed and you
have to assume a pretty high amount of
hours of full power consumption per day
it would be erroneous to look at only
the absolute power it's it's that
difference that matters but this becomes
more relevant in areas where power is
more expensive too so the argument even
just in general might not stand well
where you live for a lot of you in
Europe we know it's very expensive for
power for us it's 10 cents per kilowatt
hour so it just depends on where you
live secondly the low-end market isn't
really the place to make that argument
it matters more at the high end and
Nvidia is a Shameless consumer of a lot
of power there the power figure and
efficiency are both good on the 4060
it's just not what we think people
should use to determine whether they're
buying a card for gaming unless they're
running it nearly constantly with power
out of the way let's briefly look at
rate tracing in cyberpunk we test rate
tracing while also enabling like for
like Sr are Technologies for AMD that's
FSR for NVIDIA it's DSS2 these are
configured for equal horizontal and
vertical scaling the RTX 460 ran at 81
FPS average at 1080p with rt on and
using dlss that has it at 18% ahead of
the 3060 so the scaling is similar to
what we saw in rasterized scenarios the
4060 now leads the RX 6700 XT
establishing an advantage in RT on this
title and it has a significant lead over
the Intel cards on FSR the RX 7600 is
also left far behind down at 57 FPS
average allowing a 42% lead for the 4060
it just doesn't have the horsepower to
push both RT higher graphic settings and
then still maintain the frame rate with
both of those we won't bother showing
1440p it cut the performance more than
in half so it's not playable tomb
Raiders next the 460s 94 FPS average has
it ahead of the 7600 by 21% that's half
the lead that it had in the more RT
cyberpunk title but still enough of a
lead to demonstrate that the 4060 is
primary advantage over the 7600 other
than efficiency is rate tracing
performance the 6700 XT is basically
tied with the 460 here dragging its lead
down from previously now in F1 with rate
tracing the 4060 ran at 63 FPS average
and was about tied with the 6700 XT if
you've been listening to our 6700 XT
recommendations during the first half of
the review evaluate your RT usage when
making your final decision because this
is the area the card is the strongest
more RT might swing you back towards
Nvidia one way or the other now we're
moving to frame time charts this is a
blank template for the next chart frame
times represent the frame- to- frame
latency measured in on present on the
left axis that time is in milliseconds
so it's how long each frame takes to
present to the screen and render lower
is better but more consistent is best
and spikes greater than 8 to 12
milliseconds especially if they are
repeated and frequent become no
noticeable an ideal consistency
technically would be a nearly flat line
but that's kind of just vsync except
without cutting off the frame ceiling
realistically it doesn't work that way
though cuz you need room to scale up and
down as the workload increases or
decreases here's the first plot Total
War has the RTX 4060 maintaining frame
times around 8 milliseconds and it's
slows to 10 milliseconds as we get into
a more difficult part of the Benchmark
and then continues to scale overall Its
Behavior is consistent the largest
excursions are to 22 milliseconds and 20
milliseconds but two frames out of the
first 1,800 or so really isn't that bad
there's a couple more in there but this
is overall pretty good behavior LX 7600
is next this one has far more excursions
it's not bad overall none of these are
catastrophic but it explains why we saw
the lower frame time consistency in our
earlier average bar chart those 1% and
0.1% bars help point us toward the need
for specific frame time plots the 7600
blows out the 0.1% average with the
spikes that we're seeing to 40
milliseconds and 35 milliseconds it's
just generally less consistent and there
are enough of these to be occasionally
visible as stutters the 4060 is more
consistent here the next chart is for
Horizon zero Dawn at 1080p in this one
the RTX 460 plotted between 6 to 8
milliseconds typically about 7
milliseconds with overall consistent
frame to- frame intervals the RX 7600
had more visibly noticeable spikes on a
line graph but despite this the 7600 was
overall lower in its average frame times
and in that sense it was more consistent
too the end of the chart most clearly
illustrates the 460s slightly wider top
to bottom range finally here's a frame
time chart for cyberpunk 2077 in this
one the RTX 460 was consistent overall
the game is more variable and load so we
see this up and down pattern that's not
indicative of bad frame time pacing here
though because each frame sort of n
minus one frames or n plus one frames
are relatively consistent it's just that
the RX 7600 was better so as you saw in
the average chart the two were close
it's just AMD held the lead for this
test and that's reflected here so the
review is pretty simple this isn't as
egregiously embarrassing and bad as the
4060 TI was because the 460 TI was
surpassed as a reminder by the 3060 TI
in like 4K gaming uh that's bad it just
it's it's really terrible to be beaten
by the prior generation product that you
were supposed to be replacing it's
difficult as a reviewer as you get
deeper and deeper into sort of the a
generation a review cycle to look at the
pricing because you you kind of have to
avoid being gas lit by the companies
into this is a new normal let's look at
this objectively first of all the 7600
and the 4060 TI have both dropped in
price lately not every 4060 TI has
dropped but it's starting those Dominos
will continue to fall the company's
overbought expecting the crypto and
pandemic boom to last for eternity and
that expectation has led them to
overstuffing the market with Supply that
is actually still clearing even for the
30 series and the 6000 series of course
the longer people delay purchasing the
lower those prices will fall remember if
you bought a card in 20120 or later you
can probably skip this entire generation
the 30 series was pretty good the 6000
series also pretty good at least for
hard numbers so if you bought one of
those it's good to stay informed but
it's pretty normal
in in any time of this Market any year
to skip at least one generation plus it
just reduces waste if you're happy with
what you have now if you just want a fun
project for a weekend go for it but
waiting will probably continue to yield
drops now that said if you're buying
this card here's what we think about
each alternative in rasterization the RX
6700 XT is still competitive it's not
always as consistent in frame times but
it's often ahead and FPS enough that it
doesn't really matter it's just a better
alternative that lead however diminishes
as we enter rate tracing scenarios but
if you're able to get one close to $300
and especially if you mostly play
rasterized games it is strongly worth
considering as a top choice if we were
willing to recommend it as an
alternative to the 4060 TI at the
similar price then of course it follows
it would make sense as an alternative to
the 4060 and the pricing at least at the
time we wrote this script I just checked
and I saw three cards on new EG that
were in stock for $310 after a promo
code you have to apply and checkout and
then there were some others in the 330
range so that's pretty good next one in
rasterization the RX 7600 is often close
to the 4060 not always but now that they
$50 price drop sometimes on some of
these models which is a 170% reduction
it is close enough to be meaningful at
this budget in rate tracing the 7600
falls behind significantly in some of
our tests and that's where the 4060
starts to make more sense that's where
you need to think about it more
efficiency on the 4060 is actually
really good to give Nvidia credit
although their argument of saving money
over a 4-year period involves so many
assumptions and so many Hoops that you
have to jump through and also ignores
many of the other variables that it
becomes basically a pointless argument
at least for the money we're talking
about so that's a review it kind of
still looks like the stack is shifting a
little bit uh if you're looking for
advice my personal advice here would be
to wait unless you really need something
I if you need a card because you have a
half complete system you're side or you
need something better for what you do
fine ignore this advice if you don't
like need need one right now and you do
have the luxury of waiting a little bit
I'd wait and my reasoning is pretty
simple we have all three GPU suppliers
signaling to us loud and clear that they
need to drop the prices right now that
includes Intel and perhaps some of these
reductions are temporary sales do happen
but when I personally see all
competitors in a sphere reducing prices
and their Partners reducing prices it
starts to look like the market hasn't
settled and there may yet be new pricing
coming in uh so I'd wait but you know
that's that's just what I would do
there's your numbers
though the best thing I could say about
it uh is that it's not as embarrassing
as the 4060 TI that was pretty bad it's
it for this one though thanks for
watching as always subscribe for more go
to store. Gamers nexus.net to support us
directly and we'll see you all next time